[Musique]
vous avez des pétards des pétards à
mèche il masque de devises ont augmenté
de 8,5 et les mitraillettes ça peut être
bien là
et il faut il faut une sur le m comment
c'est pas dangereux c'est pas dangereux
ça
ici comme ça je l'allumé parents ne
l'allumé panneaux
et après il faut la c1
l'aspo
quoi
et
les gros seins marche commence à
s'installer gothard toit des gros ne
marche pas
rêver du feu
par les monts peta
hahaha
son passé
non ça klaxonne sud il faut pas faire
cela
il faut aller d'un espace qu'est un
quart d'heure jordan il ya des enfants
c'est mieux rognon tant qu'à faire
l'amour à mort pour que vous les vents
alors on avance et 14 juillet et on
n'essaie pas c'est quand on est combien
la 13 juillet c'est demain à cdn
on a droit c'est un an or
sa part pas
à part ça
c'est lui c'est lui le un petit à petit
alors un tout petit non juste un tout
petit atout pliera à tout petit
[Applaudissements]
en face on veut pas c'est dangereux
reprenez les faux pas vendre ça c'est
pas bon c'est caca tenez prenez les je
vous les donne oh bah
je m'en vais
[Musique]